I know we're Merry
Christmas we're very Christmas we
coordinated by telepathy I love a red
velvet thank you thank you you're you
got a lot of projects going on so the
holdover so let's explain what the movie
is about so the holdovers is basically
about um it takes place in Boston you
filmed in Boston recently I did shout
out to Boston I love Boston I love
touring boxing it's very cold yeah but
the fans are so game it's it's like no
other yeah yeah yeah so takes place in
Boston um 1969 to 1970 over the holdover
so the Christmas holiday um and it's
about three people that all have
different jobs at this uh boarding
school so one's a student one um works
there uh and runs like The Culinary
stuff and then one is the professor play
pip Paul Paul Gatti uh Professor hunam
it's such a great cast yes and so um
it's about these three people that are
all going through something and in a way
broken um and in this unforeseen
Circumstance the kid's parent doesn't
pick him up and so they have to be held
over so instead of my character going
home she has to stay to provide the
meals and cook for them there needs to
be another like uh faculty chaperone and
so we're forced to stay and kind of this
really beautiful way I mean it's 1969 so
you get it time period wise we wouldn't
all normally be mingling
Bute to this neutral they're all to
together and I just this idea that like
broken things can come together and like
kind of make a hole and fill yeah a
space in people's lives and I think
that's a good thing for people to like
no I call it the imperfect perfect
holiday movie because I feel like you
know a lot there's the Hallmark stuff
yeah which is beautiful it's amazing but
like there's other people in the world
that are experi in other things that
isn't Hallmark right no I my last
Christmas record is a breakup Christmas
record that you what I mean and I bet
I'm just saying cuz a l everybody's not
feeling great and your character has
lost their son like that's like that's a
heavy thing yeah a single mom that's
lost her son in the Vietnam War and she
lost her son because she didn't have
enough money to afford for him to go to
college so it's a lot of like guilt and
yeah that she's going through and so um
it was so amazing how do youall I I mean
you're on Euphoria you did this when you
have a role that's
so just devastating the story is
devastating and you have to go to those
places to be able to be the vessel for
that message and that story like how do
you climb out of that cuz you do this
day in day out while you're shooting you
know how do you climb out what do you do
afterwards you go bowling or something
what do you do like what do you I don't
know I I think for me it's a sense of
it's like um I love uh the movie
Inception so it's like the spinning top
I I have to have my spinning top ritual
or moment like I have to find some way
back to me so like I listen to certain
music or like I stay in touch with like
family members and friends like my
circle something that's like the reality
in the world out there so I don't get so
insular yeah to myself what do you do I
I mean honestly it's the same just
calling your friends and family just
connecting back with reality yeah it
would just be hard for me yeah to like
go back and forth like Ping ponging
emotionally but you said it right it's
that sense of being a vessel and I and I
I think that's why I do what I do I
think I realized early on that what we
do can really impact people yeah even if
you're doing like a comedy or ROM I've
done stuff where I'm like people have
said stuff about lost city where I'm
like you felt connected to that I love
lost city do you know what I but it's
like I say that to say love lost city
please hey hey we need sh Redemption but
we need Turner and Hooch I'm just saying
you need them all night a lot of times
when I come home from doing an intense
being in an intense world I would watch
like cartoons silly stuff I need that
kind of stuff uh to to release life is
hard so some you need that stuff to
counter act so I say that to say whether
I'm doing something silly and whimsical
or something dramatic and intense it's
all about being that vessel and so that
people can connect to it and and feel
something and can go away with it you
know what I mean beautiful
responsibility yeah we need another
break everybody you can see the
holdovers in theaters now we'll be right
[Applause]
[Music]
back
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home